welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on presenting your
research we're going to be talking about
writing NLP papers and this will hold
both for this course and for papers that
you might write in general
here's the outline of a typical NLP
paper this is not required in terms of
its structure but it is kind of freeing
to know that if you follow roughly the
structure you'll be in line with the
Norms of the field and your readers and
especially your conference reviewers
might have an easier time navigating the
ideas
we're almost always talking about a four
or eight page two column paper where
references are not counted toward this
page total and we're thinking about
papers that typically have these
components for an eight pager you'd have
your opening page with the title and
abstract and then the intro the intro
might dribble on to page two and then
you're probably going to have your
related work section after that you're
going to be starting in on the heart of
the paper you might introduce your task
and the associated data then your models
then your methods and results which
could be a kind of no-nonsense reporting
of the results close with some analysis
and then a very short conclusion these
aren't very long papers so a short
conclusion is fine
um for a four pager which is another
common format you just kind of compress
all of this and you might hope that you
can devote much less space to related
work for the sake of just explaining
your own ideas but fundamentally it's
the same structure
in a bit more detail here are some notes
on this the intro in the conventions of
NLP papers the intro is expected to tell
the full story of the paper at a high
level and indeed the abstract tells an
even higher level complete story the
intro is one layer down and by the time
the reader is done with the intro they
essentially know exactly what the paper
is going to do and it's all over but the
details
so the intro is a kind of microcosm
related work this is meant to
contextualize your work and provide
insights into major relevant themes of
the literature as a whole use each paper
or theme as a chance to articulate what
is special about your paper so I find it
helpful to think about this in a kind of
templatic format where each subsection
or paragraph of my related work section
is going to raise some kind of topical
issue or question once I've done that as
the first sentence of the paragraph then
I just more or less list out maybe with
some color the individual papers that
fall under that topical heading and then
I close the paragraph with an
explanation of how those ideas relate to
the ideas for the current paper how the
ideas from my paper complement what's in
the literature or conflict with it or
extend it or whatever else it is I try
to articulate that so that the whole
effect is to raise some crucial topics
for your area help the reader understand
what those topics are and then always
explain how the current ideas relate to
that whole messy context
so the related work is a chance to of
course cite everyone so that no one
feels upset about being excluded but
also to contextualize your ideas in this
very useful way
data this will likely be a very detailed
section if the data sets are new or your
task is new or the data is unfamiliar or
you're casting things in an unfamiliar
way this could be a much shorter section
if it's a familiar data set and familiar
task structure
then your model by which I really mean
the essence of your ideas you might not
have a model per se but presumably you
have some core ideas that you are
pursuing and evaluating
this is your chance to flesh out exactly
what those ideas are like you can use
your prior work section to kind of
contextualize and amplify and with luck
the related work really helped us
understand why you're doing the modeling
or analysis work that you're doing
then the methods this would be like your
experimental approach including metrics
Baseline models and other things like
that you're probably going to be short
on space and so you can start using
appendices for things like hyper
parameter optimization choices other
small details about compute and so forth
so that you can keep the main paper
devoted to the real essence of the
narrative
then results and I think it's best if
this is a kind of no-nonsense
description of whatever what is in the
results tables or in the results figures
and how that kind of basically relates
to the previous sections then you can
open things up a little bit when you do
analysis there's soon be discussion of
what the results mean what they don't
mean how they can be approved what the
limitations are and so forth right and
so the the nature of this section will
depend a lot on the nature of your
modeling effort and the nature of your
results
four papers that have multiple
experiments with multiple data sets
maybe even multiple models it can help
to repeat that methods results analysis
thing or even data methods results
analysis in separate subsections so that
we get kind of self-contained units of
experimental reporting and then you
might have a final analysis or
discussion section that weaves them all
together and reconnects with the ideas
from your intro and related work
and then finally a conclusion
you again want to quickly summarize what
was in the paper in a way that's not
unlike what you did in the abstract I'm
guessing there is one nice opportunity
here though which is to chart out
possible future directions and I
questions that you left open and so
forth things that people might pursue as
next steps so you at least get to have a
kind of forward-looking more expansive
final few sentences of the paper
I thought I would just offer a
scattering of interesting advice about
scientific writing things that you could
mull over let's start with this nice
kind of deconstruction from the NLP or
Stuart cheber and he's fundamentally
arguing for the rational reconstruction
approach he contrasts that first with
the Continental style in which one
States the solution with as little
introduction or motivation as possible
sometimes not even saying what the
problem was I think here he means to be
criticizing Continental philosophers
like derida but that's just my guess
readers of papers like this will have no
clue as to whether you are right or not
without incredible efforts in close
reading of the paper but at least
they'll think you're a genius
I think he means that somewhat
ironically We should strive not to write
papers in this mode
kind of at The Other Extreme is what he
calls the historical style this is a
whole history in the paper of false
starts wrong attempts near misses
redefinitions of the problem this is
better than the continental style
because a careful reader can probably
follow the line of reasoning that the
author went through and then use this as
motivation but the reader will probably
think you're a bit idle headed and in
general these papers are also very
difficult to read because it's hard to
discern what was important and what
wasn't
so ultimately what Sheba offers as a
better mode is the rational
reconstruction approach you don't
present the actual history that you went
through but rather an idealized history
that perfectly motivates each step in
the solution the goal in pursuing the
rational reconstruction style is not to
convince the reader that you're
brilliant or adult-headed for that
matter but that your solution is Trivial
it takes a certain strength of character
to take that as one's goal the better
written your paper is the more readers
will come away thinking uh that was very
clear and obvious even I could have had
those ideas it feels paradoxical but it
is the best mode to operate in
sometimes few people feel attention here
between the rational reconstruction
approach and my call elsewhere in these
lectures to really disclose as much as
you can to be open and honest about what
you did if you start to feel that
tension I would encourage you to use the
appendices to really enumerate every
false start possibly as a list so that
someone who is really trying to figure
out what happened has all the
information they need that will allow
you to in the paper tell a story that
will reach the maximum number of people
and feel informative feel like progress
and so forth
I also like this uh hint on mathematical
style from David Goss this is a document
that's full of advice a lot of it about
how to format math equations in lot Tech
but fundamentally his advices have mercy
on the reader and one part of that is to
just have your reader in mind to write
your own paper as though you were
someone consuming the ideas for the
first time and think what information
would you need what could be left out
and in general what would help most in
terms of conveying the ideas to that
hypothetical reader
Cormac McCarthy the novelist also has an
outstanding piece linked at the bottom
here full of advice for scientific
writers I think Cormac McCarthy actually
hangs out with lots of scientists at the
Santa Fe Institute and he's probably
learned a lot about how they work uh
here's one piece of advice that I'd like
to highlight decide on your paper's
theme and two or three points you want
every reader to remember this would be
stuff that you would put in the intro
and maybe structure the intro around
these ideas
this theme and these points form the
single thread that runs through your
piece the word sentences paragraphs and
sections are the needlework that holds
it together if something isn't needed to
help the reader to understand the main
theme omit it
I find this wonderfully clarifying once
I have figured out what my two or three
main points are and I have sketched them
at least in the intro then as I'm
writing and as I'm deciding on
experiments to run or to neglect I'm
always thinking about whether or not
they serve those main points and that
helps me a lot with decision making and
it helps me a lot with actually just
writing these papers in a way that I
hope is relatively clear
this strategy will not only result in a
better paper but it will be easier
easier paper to write as I said since
the themes you choose will determine
what to include and exclude and resolve
a lot of low-level questions about the
narrative
and then the final piece of advice I
wanted to offer here in general is
advice from Patrick Blackburn this is
actually about giving talks and I'll
mention it later but I think it applies
to any kind of scientific communication
the fundaments mental Insight where do
good talks or papers come from it is
honesty
a good talk or a good paper should never
stray far from simple honest
communication I have that phrase in mind
all the time as I do my research and I
find it wonderfully clarifying and
exciting to see
to round this out I thought I would just
mention two papers that I find to be
exceptionally well written I can think
of lots of papers like this I in fact
have a longer list at that papers.md
document in the course code repository
but I thought it would be fun to
highlight too and I've given the links
here the first is the Elmo paper deep
contextual word representation I like
pretty much every aspect of this paper
the intro does a great job of
contextualizing the results and
beginning to motivate the core idea
behind contextual representation and
pre-training
the actual model is presented with real
Clarity you get all the notation that
you need about how it's structured it's
a bit dense but I think that's a
consequence of a very complicated model
so I think I'm fine with that and then
you get a really exhaustive exploration
experimentally and then with follow-up
questions and hypotheses that really
give you an amazingly full picture of
Elmo and its strengths and weaknesses
it's a short paper but men it feels
jam-packed with ideas and you can learn
so much just by reading it
I also thought I would single out the
glove paper this is another really
interesting example now I think the
whole paper is Well written but the part
that I would like to single out is the
presentation of the model itself because
rarely in NLP do you get a kind of
analytic starting point that the authors
build gradually into a model they talk
about the Practical challenges of
implementing that model and why that
leads them to certain kind of
implementation choices for it and then
ultimately you get a description of the
various hyper parameters that are
involved in the final implementation by
the end of that you feel like you've
really learned something conceptual in
addition to kind of now understanding
the details of the glove model itself it
doesn't hurt that the paper is Well
written elsewhere and has incredible
results of course but I really single
out the model reporting as an
exceptional piece of writing that we
could all kind of think about as we
think about the motivations for our own
modeling ideas